there's a border that all of us share
and it keeps getting closer and closer
it's right above our heads
but it's not a border between two
countries it's actually a boundary to a
place that used to be accessible to just
a few of us
but now more and more of us can cross
this boundary
what's been dubbed the billionaire space
race
and as that happens we humans risk
messing it up
we risk sealing this border completely
so no person or object can escape
earth i want to show you how this might
happen
and what we can do to avoid it long-term
simulations show an
exponential growth in the number of
objects in space
this is low earth orbit
it's a zone about a thousand kilometers
above earth
this is a place where earth's gravity
can kind of pull you down
but just enough to put you into a
perpetual free fall
that we call an orbit satellites we send
into space can orbit earth
as far out as tens of thousands of
kilometers
but it is in this low earth orbit where
the majority of earth's satellites
reside
the satellites here give us images like
these
from telescopes like this they also
allow us to anticipate
hurricanes and observe trends like these
these satellites gave us the satellite
phone who has a satellite phone
they connect people to the internet and
they help us map the world
which is something i am very grateful
for the satellites in low earth orbit
are incredibly important
[Music]
okay so how many satellites are up there
like 50 maybe a hundred let's see
how many i'm googling on my phone let's
check
six thousand six thousand
whoa okay so there's six thousand
satellites
floating around the earth turns out that
half of those are dead
they used to be satellites now they're
just hunks of metal
the size of a small school bus spinning
around our planet
of the 3 000 or so working satellites
some are military
some are government but more than half
of them are commercial
sorry did that land let me just say it
again half of these satellites
are commercial they're from private
companies i was once a child with a
dream
let me explain why that's a big deal for
most of the time that we've been
traveling to space
space has been a government thing it was
russia that put up the first satellite
into low earth orbit in the 50s
it was the cold war so the us was like
we can do that too and we're gonna do it
better so they created
nasa and focused on getting as many
satellites as they could
up into space we need science this
is for the american people the most
critical problem of all
a bunch of these launches just sort of
blew up because they were really
terribly made but eventually they got
satellites into space they had something
to prove space was a political thing at
the time
president eisenhower reassures the
nation that russia's success
with the first satellite does not
indicate a serious lag in american
rocket research
and the us poured tons of money into
making this happen
and they did our satellite is definitely
on orbit
so at this point space was a government
thing
but boy has that changed
[Music]
in recent years there's been an
explosion of satellites being put into
space
that are not from the government or
military but from private businesses
to the point where today in 2021 there
are over a hundred
private companies that are building
vehicles to take more stuff
into space this is a space economy it's
a big deal and because of that
more and more stuff is going into space
this year
2021 we've already launched 1100
objects into space that's the same total
as we did in all of 2020
and nearly 10 of what we've ever sent up
into space the numbers are going up
faster and faster and faster every
single year
but there's a problem potentially a huge
problem
with all of this stuff going up into
space
and that problem is that space at least
low earth orbit this area right around
our earth
is limited let me explain what i mean
here
you have all of these objects floating
around our earth
more and more every year so what happens
if two of these satellites by chance
collide
so what satellites collide and maybe
some rich company loses some money
who cares no no no no no
no no no no reminder that these objects
are flying around
earth at 28 000 kilometers an hour
that's eight kilometers a second in one
second
eight kilometers they go around earth 12
times per day
and at that speed things get a little
bit crazy a few years ago
a fleck of debris like a little piece of
dust that was one millimeter in diameter
like the tip of a
sharp pencil a tiny fleck was floating
through low earth orbit
at this speed and it hit a satellite
solar panels
and this tiny fleck of dust left a giant
gash in the panels
it was one millimeter in diameter in
2009 a collision
between a defunct russian spacecraft and
an
operational commercial satellite created
this exact
kind of shrapnel cloud completely
disintegrated
more than 2 300 hunks of space junk that
are now floating around our planet
at 28 000 kilometers an hour
this shrapnel at one point put the
hubble telescope at risk
and it sort of freaked people out in an
instant
two objects turn into thousands of
objects
all with new paths floating around our
earth so the fear here
is that what if this became a chain
reaction one collision
makes more debris which leads to another
collision
which means even more debris and more
collisions and suddenly low
earth orbit becomes a minefield of space
junk hurling around our planet at
deathly speeds
and launches a domino effect that would
wipe out our space infrastructure
leaving us trapped on the surface of
earth for generations beneath a violent
cloud
of speeding shrapnel unable to send
anything up to space
for a very long time
this is the nightmare scenario it's a
scenario that is
portrayed in the movie gravity which is
a very good movie
quick pause to thank today's sponsor
policy genius
policy genius is a place where you can
compare quotes for life insurance
life insurance is one of those things
that you sort of don't think about very
often
you don't want to think about it because
it's sort of associated with like big
what ifs
but it's one of these things that is
wise to have and especially while you're
young you can lock in a really low rate
on life insurance
i actually just went through this whole
process i signed up using policy genius
and was able to compare quotes from a
bunch of different life insurers
i did this all very quickly and then got
on the phone with an expert at policy
genius and soon i had a life insurance
policy so now i am insured i have life
insurance and it feels
actually really good you can save 50 or
more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius
and you can get covered in as little as
a week for me it was super quick i
didn't have to go
do a health exam or anything i was just
able to do all the health stuff
over the phone and i got covered it was
like 15 or 20 minutes of my time policy
genius never
sells your information or anything like
that which i am a big fan of
they're just simple and they save you
money so head to policygenius.com
johnny harris going to that link which
is also in my description
help support this channel but it also
gets you started today
on saving money with life insurance all
right let's get back to space borders
eventually of course over the years this
debris would slowly fall into the
atmosphere it would lose altitude and it
would burn up in our atmosphere
but that would be generations of a world
without satellites
a world that is sealed from space okay
okay listen listen this is not gonna
happen
anytime soon by all counts we are safe
from the chain reaction the
probabilities are very low
it isn't likely right now there's a lot
of space up there space
the final frontier but we are sending up
thousands of satellites per year now
this may not be an issue now it
certainly will be soon
so what do you do with this we're in the
midst of this new space race
just like the one between the soviets in
the us in the 50s but this time
it's not governments it's like this guy
and a bunch of guys just like him
and they're the ones who are racing to
space
and they don't really care about the
potential scenario of a chain reaction
do you know why because they have
investors to please and a world to show
that they can privatize space the
fastest
so let's talk about the us government
really quick of the 3 000 working
satellites
about 2 000 of them are american they
come from american companies or the
american government
so you would expect the american space
government agency
nasa to be the responsible steward of
low earth orbit and make sure that these
private space companies are at least
following some traffic rules
when they send them up into space so
that they don't collide
alas no one including nasa
wants to be the one to slow down the new
space race
instead they are focusing on quote
accelerating a thriving commercial
economy
in low earth orbit the us government is
sort of doing what it did in the 50s
we got to get an edge on this new space
thing and let's focus on just getting as
much stuff
up as we can so nasa is helping to fund
these private space companies
who are sending up so many satellites
and objects into space
like spacex elon musk's company is
sending up
60 satellites a month just like
60 satellites just being like thrust
into space
every month and he's asked for a lot
more he wants to get 42
000 up there like that's what that's
what he's asking for that's what he's
asking for approval for 42
000 just 42 000. so far he's gotten
approval for 12
000. amazon is now getting into the
space game
they've been approved to send up over 3
000 we're not
slowing down so clearly the race is on
and no one's thinking too hard about
traffic you're blaming me for the
traffic
should i so how do we avoid filling up
low earth orbit
and avoid the collisions that could
potentially cause
a devastating chain reaction these
companies are taking some protocol like
spacex will send up these satellites in
like a caravan
like a line of satellites which looks
really trippy by the way i was out
stargazing for my
galaxy video last year and i looked up
and i saw this like perfect line
of blinking dots in the sky and i was
like
what is happening i was sure that i was
seeing like a ufo like this is this is
it like
i have witnessed i've had my encounter
with extraterrestrials i
serious it was a good existential moment
for me i was like what is happening
20 minutes later i looked it up and
learned about
the caravans that spacex does
they do this so that all of the
satellites are in the same
path so that they have way less
likelihood of colliding
because they're not just on random paths
they're like all together so yeah these
private companies are taking some
precautions
but as we all know you can't rely on
private companies to regulate themselves
for the good of everyone
like are we really going to be like you
guys
regulate yourself and we'll all be safe
and everyone will be good no
that's just that's not how it works what
we need is mutually agreed upon laws
on how stuff can be launched into low
earth orbit
so that we actually have some traffic
management in space
there are no rules of the road in space
no formal agreements on how traffic
should behave
in low earth orbit in other words this
is the wild west
wait isn't there like space law like
treaties
like the outer space treaty the moon
treaty
the international space station yeah but
none of these things talk about traffic
all these countries have signed these
treaties that just say that space is for
everybody no one can conquer space no
star wars
that isn't very reassuring closest any
treaty gets to addressing the space
traffic thing
says that quote states shall be liable
for damage caused by their space
objects in other words if you send an
object up
and your country damages an object from
another country
your country has to take responsibility
in some form
but wait does that actually happen
remember that defunct russian spacecraft
that collided with the commercial
satellite in 2009
who took responsibility and wait was it
the russian satellite that hit the
commercial one
or was it the commercial one that hit
the russian one
like how do you dole out responsibility
and blame
when you're talking about two satellites
just floating through space who happened
to run into each other
so in the end the responsibility landed
squarely on the shoulders of
nobody how did we get into this mess
decision makers couldn't even agree on
who was responsible
for launching the commercial satellite
in the first place because multiple
countries
were involved with launching it and they
hadn't registered it with the un like
they promised they would back in some
treaty in 1972. i mean it's a total
mess there is no order or regulation
or clarity in space law which right now
is fine
but soon it won't be so here we are with
no traffic rules
no history of holding anyone accountable
for unintentional space collisions
and we're about to send up tens of
thousands more satellites
what we need is productive cooperation
like humans have been able to do in so
many aspects of our global
international system the international
space station is a great example
it has functioned as a multinational
collaborative project in space
unfortunately what i've learned is that
when there's competition among countries
a lot of these cooperative efforts sort
of go out the window
there's growing tension between two
superpowers china and the us
and china is in the middle of
constructing their own space station for
low earth orbit
india is preparing to send their own as
well
this is competition not cooperation our
existing space law
which was all sort of drafted in the 60s
and 70s
never anticipated private companies
sending up
thousands of satellites and it didn't
anticipate china
and india and the us competing for
space power our desire to explore space
is
not just about showing how powerful and
innovative we are
so much technology has come from
our space exploration from solar cells
to cochlear implants to fire fighting
technology
the development of the microchip which
was majorly accelerated by nasa and now
microchips drive our entire world
the pursuit of reaching out into space
has consistently driven
meaningful innovation so this is
important
we should absolutely protect the future
of
this really wonderful thing that humans
have done
we've escaped our atmosphere we've
escaped gravity
and we've learned so much in the process
so
there are a lot of objects in space
they're floating around
and there's a body of treaties and law
that is way outdated my hope is that as
we send these thousands and thousands of
satellites into space we consider the
implications of what happens if we get
too hasty
send too much stuff up and things start
to run into each other
it's not worth the risk in my mind if we
don't look ahead
we could turn space from a border that
we can all cross
together and learn together as human
beings into a border that is
impenetrable
that's dangerous that keeps us trapped
here on this warming planet unable
to continue to explore the world of
outer space
you